[Musik]
über zwei sache soll man besser
schwieger wenn man kein schritt vom zu
und will riis über religion und politik
so sagt der volksmund
mehrere wird über beides hat das
willkommen zur stadt und religion en hei
am bildschirm und mir beide gast im
studio
wir sind welche stoffe christ großen
wünsche vor zürich und der priester
klinsi ist theologin und fdp politikerin
kommen sie sind in den letzten wochen
häufig in den medien dreht ich gekommen
sync wo es um fehler und politik dort wo
sie zusammen mit dem cvp präsident
gerhard pfister gegründet im vorgespräch
zu den handel kann sie mir dann aber
zeit das stimmt so nicht ganz und der
begriff thinktank sie die irre führen
was ist denn jetzt genauso gut gefahren
oder groupe de réflexion pkw fing ich
denke außerdem sind eine erfindung der
medien
in der westschweiz ist es allerdings so
dass fink denkt und ruft durch reflexion
sind effektiv die beiden zweit- oder 18
bezirks und reflexion der unterschied
mit dem fink denkt an verschiedenen
stellen fragen ob sich eine bildrate
dass sie dem sinn hätte das für das
missverstanden ist sorgt das fängt den
gesanglichen institution wir sind grand
edition
wir sind ganz im sinn ein simpler groupe
de réflexion wo sich darüber nachdenkt
wie soll sich viele nachhaltig in
öffentliche diskurs edlinger und
erstellen müssen vielleicht aber warnen
die hand der gehabt habe für das
gespräch zur gewürzter erhält man
üblicherweise ablehnt jeder kreis
kontroverses gespräch mit bei anderen
stelle für das stofftier den
grundsätzlich auf ein verhaltenes
befehle und politik war es gar nicht so
sehr uns was ausstoß sind auch zwei
überlegen sein
in der letzten jahre wenn man von
politik und religion brett ist es
meistens friesland sie was verständlich
ist mit einer völlig anderen religionen
landschaft mit lawinen
verschiedene ist allenfalls dennoch
diskussion in zusammenhang mit
diebstählen das stichwort viele schüler
initiative für firmen das ist ein taxi
die hand als gefragt wie können sich
kräne nachhaltiger in die öffentliche
diskussion die politische diskussion
einbringen so dass sie nicht einfach
quasi sich damit frieden und das
wiederholen was vor der materie vor der
gewerkschaft der wirtschaftsverband so
lange zeit wurden ist traurig sie es
geht so ein schönes wort vom hof ski
natürlich weiß auch die zynische sich
bekannter zeit kriegen sie in sachen wie
ein hund wohinter ein stück fleisch
heranziehen permanent frage vor der zeit
hinterher
das ist natürlich völlig überspitzt sie
aber mir ist das so vor hoch wenn alle
player der diskussion gehabt denn sie in
krisen nach und dann gesagt was sie an
oder zu erfinden und auch nicht die
frage ich sie wie hören sie sich
nachhaltig die diskussion ich bringe ich
selber tränen aus es ist ein thema
setzen einige prozess anstoßen
also das ist auch der hintergrund sie
vor der groupe de réflexion tatsächlich
das müsste ja eigentlich ganz in ihrem
sinn sie wie sie als kinder nachhaltig
bringen in gesellschaftspolitische
diskussion habe ich als kompetent ganz
tief gerufen ja will also ist meine
erfahrung geht es vor der gaststätte
denkt denkt über habe das thema jetzt
zieht der diskussion sondern immer nur
aus ich kille politisch oder politisch
wenn auch einfach zeit und da auch die
haut opposition natürlich muss die
politik sie wenn sie jung ist politisch
biblisch politisch aber gekonnt
schmunzelt wenn sie sich vor dem hohen
wohin auch an bord hat die das areal
hatte genau das bild bruch zum sagen
dass kiel asylpolitik sie was geht denn
haben
viele darf keinen strom ziehen wenn es
um nachhaltige problemfeld das hat er
als pfarrer von st viel zeit und viel
ich das als letzte das ist bis einfach
im kantonsrat sie zu rodeln in einer
institution sitzung und dankt aus wenn
man vor ort als truppe im grossmünster
oder viel energie ist an collodi dobos
herrisch und muss entscheiden
die entscheidungen die man fallen und
die entscheidung sind nicht nach der
entscheidung von der politik sondern
meistens ist einfach vordergrund dick
smith und seine politik denkt der viele
hinten aber das haben wir darüber
diskutiert mit gelang es ist einfach
haben im rat sitzen
es ist viel schwieriger ist das wird
jetzt ein brauch politik ist stand die
die volk vor kompromiss man ist bemüht
fürs gemeinwohl quasi die option fürs
maximum satz holen
es geht gar nicht anders spielen sie
steht was ich als fantastisch sie stehen
es sind kompromiss doch heute einfach
ein wenig signature und mit dem sinnigen
schönheit untergang sondern ich muss
permanent ich muss mit antenne zu einer
irgendwie eine lösung finden
ich würde sagen es ist einfach sondern
ich würde sagen es sind zwei
unterschiedliche positionen
wenn sie auf der kanzlerin wenn sie in
büros menschen sind wenn ich in europa
und ich wäre theologen haus in dem sie
eigentlich einmal zwei perspektiven
es ist einfacher sondern es sind zwei
unterschiedliche positionen denn ziehe
ich meine das foto kommt also große
menschen die ich gebe ihnen zwei
beispiele wo politik der vielen
kritischen politisch behälter needle
park osterburg weist das war der stoff
ist doch die sternsinger mit china lief
vor sein kann erzählt der plaut speziell
monika stocker nach einer fast und aus
dem schiff ist die vier säulen
prävention passiert die der politik wo
alle parteien bis heute die
unterstützung erhält den kollektor als
kam mit der chilene ihre ideale in die
70er jahre habe ich sie
nach system user hat das sensorium show
von x factor und der droht kurz herr im
zweitrat reiz wo die ganz flüchtlings
thematik helene bevor es überhaupt 2015
großer krieg wieder nachhaltig immer
wieder einmal das politisch bespielt
sozialpolitisch gespielt und aus der
politik erklärt ich bin seit und seine
spieler aber ich bitte wo er gelebt und
seit wann sie schon sagen wir hinkriegen
da muss ich ihnen es geht genauso gut
spielen muss ich ihnen sagen kann und
das hat doch nur damit sie teufel die
arosa dass in der schweiz das ziel und
politik als mit den angenehmen machen
haben die kritiker vorher öfter kommen
aber erst mal wurden einfach auf
sie sind theologie und sie sind
politikerin
verstehen sie sich auch als ein
religiöser mensch ich verstehe dass ein
gläubiger mensch ich mache einen
unterschied zwischen religion und
zwischen christlichem glauben
ich verstehe nicht was gläubige macht
und wir spielten in ihre politische
meinung finden das ist effektiv ist wage
ich es spielzeit verstanden mit wenig
zufrieden
es spielt natürlich mit aber ich habe da
aber immer quasi maxime was kommen aus
den verschiedensten kompromiss wunder
muss egal was ist das optimum wonach
eine rolle für das allgemeinwohl es geht
ja der katholischen soziallehre dass der
begriff vom allgemein bauen also das
spielt ganz klar eine rolle
ich frage mich aber immer dass wir das
war schon nach sehr da bin ich ganz bei
ihnen
was heißt das jetzt für die hypo
sozialpolitik wo sie habe mit seiner
karriere wir haben wir nur eine story
die ganze welt was heißt das eigentlich
hätten und auf einen ganzen zentraler
punkt um ihre folgen der infektion
was heißt das wird bestimmt ist
was hat das 1 1 für die nachricht dass
man hier so viele starke hilfe
beanspruchen
was heißt das konkret bestimmt die
schwächere das sind migranten das rennen
nicht einfach sind dass migranten es
sind der brauch gebracht und wieder sind
ein sommerlied und sachverstand versuche
ich die optik streets bringe aber ich
kann nicht einfach sich argumentieren
sondern wo sie denn sie nach antworten
danke und handle das heißt ich muss
immer auf alle von ihm entscheid wie ich
mich verhalte wenig abstimmen wenn ich
im rat abstimmen wenn ich nachher aus
stimmbürgerinnen aus schweizerin
abstimmen und nur sich aber infolge
selbstverständlich mit bedanken
apropos von quelle ist jetzt sie nimmt
die verantwortung wird folge vor ihr
eine klinik nach letztlich nicht so wie
du dich gar nicht glauben dass wir jetzt
so zu hart zeit sondern ich mir sind
viele fall dass man sich zeitig celtic
argumentiert das werde ich noch mal noch
nie da meine ps2 hat ja bekannt die fall
in deutschland mit der kanzlerin über
ganz klar argumentieren als stehen im
fall von der migration auf der anderen
seite sehe sogar als christlich
argumentiert dass die stadt mit
gemieteten transporter mega und hoffe
dass überhaupt nicht zur jetzt sagen die
einen christlichen das sind weniger
christlich die eine sind enthalten ist
wie viele anderen halbe wunder sorgen
heute ist sondern ich glaub ich beide
haben sich beide politischen lager die
zwischen und christina und das ist das
was uns dann wie es wirklich sehr
aufgestoßen ist dass webseiten auf diese
initiative aus christlicher sicht nur so
und nicht anders abstimmen
nix also es gibt verschiedenste argument
vorbei
es gibt wenig
ausnahme vielleicht acht prozent für
politische fragen wo ich meint die
berufliche perspektive muss nicht
verhandelbar ist ganz klar wenn ich
irgendwie auf die dämpfer folgte das ist
das ist gar nicht so vital aus letztere
hätten sich in deutschland rückschritte
im zusammenhang mit terrorismus
komplize allfällige komplize dem sind
noch helfen kann halt verdammt sich
quasi geständnis ablegen also folgt ist
frank apartheid und überall dort wo
natürlich wird man sicherlich indizes
haben den handel da gibt's nichts
erklären das ist völlig selbständig und
das klima ist sanft und immer wieder
appelliert das ist also das problem ich
gebe ihnen wenig positionierter nicht
immer kantons auktionen als pfarrer der
boss ist fordert meint bin ich als
glauben das heißt als demo zu god in der
nachfolge vor dem christus nur
öffentlich mit der politische behörde
gestritten hat bin ich der maxi nix und
verantwortete knie hat uns einordnen
sondern immer an fall selber muss im
moment nachhaltig entscheidung
nachhaltig entscheiden heißt so sieht
riskiert tue nicht das was sie fordert
dass man die soziale politische probleme
durch sachverstand linie denkt denkt
dass du nicht doch ständig mit dem land
bearbeitet
nur unterschied die stehe wenn ich als
pfarrer der glaube öffentlich verkünde
vor der kanzler muss ich am ende die
stadtwerke fallen angemahnt und muss
mich dann entscheide und der unterschied
zu wenig warten notruf was politik
weil ich immer andere politische
verständnis politisch versteht ist von
mir heißt selbstverständlich nur sich
und herzlich wie jede idee schmid sich
politischer seite nur das können sie mir
das nicht erklären dass sie den 30 jahre
mir dann der vorwurf
politisch hat das nichts politisch bin
ganz links sie ist so gelaunt 15 uhr
eine kleine aus erstens trifft das sogar
nimmt zu auch links und rechts ist hat
sich mittlerweile jeder völlig teil wie
es für schon bald auch endlich ihnen
verschiedene spiele es stimmt ja
übrigens jahrgang
die pläne sehen dass und einmal
bischofskonferenzen bischofskonferenz
hier ist die frage was bio egk dort sind
die meisten sie 81 prozent auf der linie
also es ist völlig unkompliziert
anschuldigung erste buch bringt weil ich
mich für migrationspolitik so europa um
für die homosexualität hier setzte werd
ich meistens vor der bürgerlichen
parteien trifft stebe politisch weil ich
aber im bereich wurde politik
bürgerliche position hat wird überhaupt
mit angriffe
das ist mein vater diskutieren sie mir
das erklärt kantons politikerin machen
vielleicht ganz gut in unser durch
interne diskussion im iran zwei spiel
vorbereitet zeigt es geht mir andere
themen
wovor rechts und von links übrigens
kritisiert wird uns im zweiten spiel für
die grenzen sind unterschiedlich
er ist aus spittal soldat gemacht und da
habe ich persönliche waffe eine pistole
ausbildet wurde
sie könnten optimiert als armee sorger
und offizier und ich habe mir
vorgestellt würde ich die waffe brauchen
die menschen fahren
ich weiß was ich die bibel steht du
sollst nicht töten töten ist nicht
erlaubt moralisch und jesus gott noch
gewitter und zeit aber endlich einen
schlussstrich zu ziehen
es geht das dilemma mit jesus helfen
schwache stoffe darunter tätig und wenn
unschuldige opfer von brutaler gewalt
werden kann man nicht einfach tatenlos
zu beruhigen oder norwegen man muss halt
man muss es nur mit allen mitteln also
zieht wo jesus klappt hat sich über das
läge vor der heiligen schrift gestritten
wurde
jesus hat die diskussion betont dass es
eis geburt gibt wo über eine andere
stadt
das gebot von der liebe zu gott und zu
der mannschaft dass sex perspektive und
der reggae biblische text grasser werde
mir sieht und genau das jedes gebot ist
fundament vor der aktuell viel zitierte
christlicher wert es geht darum dass mir
grundlage für verantwortungsvolle und
verbindliche beziehe geschaffen wird
sich dabei um gleichgeschlechtliche oder
heterosexuelle partnerschaften handelt
hat die minen augen der kritik ich liebe
berlin koordiniert das jetzt schon
zwischen zweitplatzierte umfrage
behauptet die andere dem sie nicht
irgendein grund war hat appelliert liebe
gottes barmherzigkeit oder das ist
bigott vertrag hatte dies gefordert mit
bibel aus der bibel direkt abgeleitet
wie müsste ich muss stellen jetzt in der
konkreten abstieg was hat sich denn die
karten wenn sie irgendwas ist weniger
exportabhängig richtige position
also ich habe ganz klar rausgestochen
dass er dabei nie zur sache sondern wen
konkret mit der bibel quasi abgeleitet
werden wie man sich politisch muss
positionieren ich meine christoph sieg
ist also damit das ist das was wir für
evangelikale wo in amerika mitte
betriebe oft strahlen
kein vorwurf an die fundamentalisten
vorwerfen ganze bibel wirklich fordern
gerade auch leicht gemacht
bei mir hat bei theologie studiert und
wir wissen auch dass beta wird das labor
ist wo wir seit ich meistens stehen im
rat bestellen würde gemacht und nicht
studieren wer jetzt glaubt stehen im
asylgesetz unterschiedliche positionen
und nach der bibel die achte wahl haben
register für und gegen das meine ich
auch nur rund regierung beschädigt da
kann machen
das sind klare positionen monika für
buchungen grad vor der reise wo sie
jetzt sagen dass der draht und zwar ich
bin sagt sie ich bin 20 jahre also ich
kann genau die widersprüche beliebigen
group erlaubt das von homosexualität um
eine kollegin mit tracht zeit dass man
das muss positioniere ich hoch
kontroverse dotiert und zeichnet dieses
problems und die uns nur dann
unterscheidet man zur abstimmung also
ich sage so hans w
ja aber es kommt ihr da stehen mit drei
mal ausreden wieder abstimmen
die unterscheidung mache ich halt nicht
wenn in der abstimmungsvorlage und genau
so einige position abstimmen
und das ist nett es vor der bibel her
hat die abstimmung skodas diskussionen
das sind das sind reflektiert die
nachhaltige überlegen immerhin wusste
position vor der liebe wo jeder mensch
gilt verhalten gegenüber an der religion
muslimen und verhalten gegenüber sexuell
orientierte können umsätze unserer
gesellschaft und das muss man auch mit
partizipation und politischer aber wenn
kinder sich so bald eröffnet dann kannst
du damit auch andere unter umständen
anders stellt sind was sie sich auf die
standspur nicht in ihrem interesse sie
das können der akteure ist die akteurin
ist wofür der zusammenhalt da ist sind
es geht uns darum ist neben tommy
schwimmer die awo doktor und obdachlose
die gleiche truppe im schillerpark im
grossmünster laverty obdachlose und
professoren wo zusammen sind das zimmer
sie aber der zusammenhalt der hammer
inhalt reformieren da hat in der
auseinandersetzung sei bisher dass
mediziner des ec kann aber nicht jeder
hat passig und möglich ab 30 grad grenze
geschickt auf passive uhf lösung
auseinandersetzung habe nur sagen ich
mich instrumentarium für politisch
nachhaltige position dass vor der
katholische viele übernommen und reaper
33 prinzip sehen urteilen handeln mit
der eigenen position
aber ich bezwungen als pfarrer ist
handlicher und handel heißt abstimmen
also wenn sich seit hand mit dem sie
neben dem zusammenhalt ist es nicht so
dass er begreift die polarisierung und
das finde ich jetzt wirklich störend
finde ich übrigens ein und ausgängen
ganzen stark hofgang hat dass die
polarisierung der gesellschaft anfang
wie die politik hat dass die npd motto
die helenen er fragt auch noch mal
befüllt wird
viele müssen rein gehauen dass die
stadtteile eben versuchen verschiedenste
lüth wo rechts links streifen
schwarz-grün sind dir eigentlich wissen
predigte ich wissen artikel als gott den
er liebt eine frauen um politik und man
vergisst irgendwo dass der kuchen die
sonne legen die zahl noch um das ich
nenne das immer so ist meine meinung ist
ja noch mal bis ganz anderswo viel mehr
ist als politik und da scheint mir dass
die polarisieren anstatt dass man
versucht die lücke zusammenzuhalten die
verschiedenen gruppen das mit drogen
ausgleichen machen oder ein ganzes
zumindest aus krina genau das gemacht
was man in der politik machen das
polarisiert
oft aber sind vielfach tägliche der
freche fragen sind sie diesmal in der
felix interpret ich vor so politisch wie
sie es tut mir gut tun kritisch sahen
verstanden dass ein polizist als
schwierig oder delikat seit einer saison
aus der vorderkante slogan aber das ist
ein verantwortungsvoller das wie ist es
ihnen und was noch besser ist und da
einfach klar wundertätige rezept oder
zumindest so finde ich möchte schnell
feststellen
grill soll politisch ich glaube da
herrscht einigkeit prag und telemark und
wie ihr interview so in der form wie
sollte ich mal grundsätzlich das
spannungsverhältnis zwischen keller und
religion auf der einen seite und staat
und politik auf der anderen seite
dadurch immer spannungsverhältnis sie
das ist nicht nur bewunderung das
eigentlich immer wieder und warum
eigentlich gott welcher spruch sie 2011
dass sich unser boot aus dem strom
gesellschaft und das ist sie 2000 jahren
konfliktbeladene tradition und wenn man
500 jahre jetzt das erinnere die jury
der rüstet man die konflikte die ganze
sache ist ich es nur aus meiner
biografie freeskier sage ich hole mir
aus der sportzone rose dass ich immer
mit mir suchen mich im politischen feld
vernehme ich kann ständig nur auf der
kanzler sondern weil ich am tag
nachrichtenlosen ich ständig immer das 1
wo muss ich mit dem hund sie und wo er
sich mit dem kanäle
diese politische haltung zurück wissen
und ich kann ihnen sagen nicht immer
richtig aber was ich ihnen sagen ist mit
dem quiz und nehmen glaube steinig so
war dass ich da bin ich immer hin dass
ich normativ zugunsten von schwächsten
durch orientalische politische aufgabe
das anne von novelle sagte jeder
bundesländern statt über die us richtig
aufs wohl vor der schwächste genauso wie
die bibel ganz genau welche herrscht
jedoch relativ hat doch noch viel vor
es gehört bei den schwächsten pinsel das
kommt ja und ich muss nicht nach schwarz
und finden ihre studie hat mir vor der
hütte deutsche niedrig
das sind explodiert liegt wo höchste
gesellschaft unser flügen und das
wüssten sie genau als politikerin hof
sehr dass sie das wissen wer das ist
und das sind nicht nur die jetzt
öffentlich stigmatisierte gruppierungen
sondern das sind die versteckte armut
wobei mir auch apple bietet vielen und
wo mir vor der vielen und zwar komisch
vor religiöse gemeinschaften unglaublich
viel sache und diakonische arbeit machen
und diakonie heißt halte politisch tätig
war auswärts klar mit mir reden events
in einem fall wird das es unbestritten
dass jemand veteran auf die fed die
krise politisch sie dass pany zumindest
reflex musik häme geht es mir nicht
ständig nadel zu sagen wir sind fahren
sie also es ist in wirklichkeit wissens
konflikt sie christus kommission ist
dass viele hat sich zur größten der fünf
erzielten dagegen aber damit zu
argumentieren dass jetzt die religiöse
fest also das wäre die sache ist wird
das wäre über die gewählt aussetzen
klientelpolitik sie was wir im übrigen
parteien eher schwach dafür hilft also
da geht es jetzt wirklich kreppel und
machen sich anfragen bei anderen
abstimmungen natürlich noch mal zurück
initiativen schützlinge haben
wenn das onyx arbeitsverbot wenn das
wird und das ist eine andere frage aber
wird mir jetzt quasi bis zu fünf stunden
trotzdem kaufen oder auf deck die den
tankstellenshop das ist für status
konfession ist zum zucker auf die sache
als ganze partner sky wird der finger
auf der burg punkt lag die die sozial
schwachen die schwache die den die
vereinsamte das darf man die autobahn a2
anschaffen unterschätze die hypo am rand
sind ganz speziellen anders evangelium
seit gleichzeitig dass es macht sich
stark dass er zwischen oben und unten
zwischen und und weniger zwischen rechts
und links ein wenig den kopf gebaut wird
sondern von bord sind alle sind die
kantone titel mancher würden und dort in
das vertrauen und die dämme sind sehr
anti evangelisch weil er betreut wird
die eingerichtete weniger sondern es
geht auch darum die mannschaft um
einzelne stachel im fleisch erziehung
und die da bin ich ruinen der meinung
mit dem was jetzt von seiten einiger
hundert im himmel wie es kommt aus
norden
das heißt ich wie nötig meint bietet
select riesige und das ist wirklich das
thema als stachel im fleisch wo sie
genau wissen wo immer durch man sich
richtig glauben mit dem markt verbindet
denn ich sie im regal korrumpiert zu
werden
und das thema das begleitet dc2 beispiel
formschwache die schon 50 jährige ruby
mir brühl wo suizid alisch was
eigentlich bewusst gespielt wurde aus
dem arbeitsmarkt und das ist doch
scheibe dass mancher bild das ich muss
fit und immer muss perfekt sein wenn ich
jetzt vom militär die ganze politische
bemühungen von der sozialhilfe wird mir
schlecht was für das menschenbild
transportiert wird weil ich den vor mir
habe und er mir brille zeitig hausnummer
news ich eine schlechte füße weil ich
überhaupt aufs sozialamt kann müssen sie
mit sonniger politischer prozess wird es
manche bild transportiert das pässe
jede/r glücklich wo sozialhilfe dort
empfangen
und da muss kille weil sie keinen sturm
wohl geblieben josef und st so dicht
meine lieben politikerinnen und
politiker hätte ich mir sind schon fast
am schluss ist sehr beleidigend euro
positionen ganz wesentlicher schluss
folgte sie bei die frau akyün wenn sie
am nächsten sonntag wird der verein
viele prediger zu welchem thema wetter
so genannte schwache doch damit ist die
letzte frage an richtung erwischt wenn
in wirklichkeit hat die einzige
politische vorstoß lancieren so was war
das dass wir zum thema musik vor ort wo
flaggen werden will die hochbetagte vor
der betagte sind das 53 steht also das
ganze problem vor der flach vor der
hochbetagte altersheim oder die hi
das hdt stützt die platten gehörige
wofür 66 gesehen wo heute zum beispiel
nur 50 prozent schaffen und dafür die
anderen 50 prozent oder für die wand
will pflegen und hegen dass ich arbeit
und ich so sozial politisch ökonomisch
meisten tiere des bostoner parlament ist
sicher dass gott viktor ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich für das stört berlin
christoph der name sie jetzt mit und
mongolen wurz mit in der städte tantal
aus dem 16 jahrhundert steht vor der
kommunisten fast ganz zerstört ist
loswerden so wird wieder in betrieb
[Musik]